salut c'est une seconde courte vidéo
aujourd'hui pour vous parler d'apple il
y aurait un problème sur la fabrication
du futur iphone 6,1 pouces à venir
aujourd'hui courte vidéo dimanche oblige
peut donc aller à l'essentiel je vous
parle aujourd'hui d'apple parce qu'à une
nouvelle qui est tombée pourquoi une
nouvelle
une rumeur qui nous vient du site
japonais macotakara - jp appelant
rencontrerait un problème avec sa chaîne
de fabrication sur son modèle 6,1 pouces
alors pour vous rappeler un petit peu
vous remettre tous en mémoire cette
année c'est une info de mines qui compte
qu'une prédiction qui est là depuis un
petit moment qui a priori semble être
toujours la bonne puisque tout le monde
en parle il devrait y avoir trois
nouveaux iphone qui arriverait au mois
de septembre lors de la keynote d'apple
un iphone de 5,10 tous avec un écran
oled d'un iphone de 6,5 pouces avec un
écran oled d'iphone de 6,1 pouces avec
un écran lcd le modèle le moins cher le
plus abordable modèle low cost c'est
justement sous la halle à qui poserait
problème
l'écran de cet iphone 6 incluant tous
très fournie par la société japan
display avec qui apple bossent déjà
depuis quelques temps ils doivent
fournir une dalle full activistes à lire
une dalle qui vient quasiment au bord de
l'appareil avec des bordures toujours
plus réduite vous auriez des bordures de
0,5 mm à savoir sur l'iphone dit vous
avez des bordures de 1 mm donc des
bordures deux fois plus réduite pour un
modèle beaucoup moins cher sauf qu'il y
aura un problème sur la chaîne de
fabrication est forcément y aurait du
retard alors que les iphone 5 2 8 pouces
et 6 5 pouces devrait arriver dès mois
de septembre
aussitôt qu'apple aurait fait ça qui
note pour acheter celui ci vous devriez
patienter le mois de novembre
ça n'aura pas le petit peu le problème
car en compte rappelle l'année dernière
vous présenter l iphone 8,8 plus et
l'iphone 10 l'iphone 8,8 plus haute est
dispo très rapidement ils maîtrisaient
la conception c'était beaucoup plus
rapide est par contre un problème
technique et on a dû attendre le mois de
novembre pour avoir les fonds dits l'a
appris au ce serait la même chose pour
le modèle le moins cher le sixième opus
voilà pour cette mauvaise nouvelle si
vous voulez acheter le smartphone le
moins cher cette année le ch apple il va
falloir vous armer de patience mais on
parle que deux mois de plus et pas non
plus énorme mais ça peut quand même être
décevant et à peu risque de souffrir par
rapport à la concurrence
alors si vous voulez vraiment ce produit
vous pourriez attendre de mode plus
dites nous ce que vous en pensez est ce
que vous trouvez que ces rumeurs ces
trois modèles vous paraissent plausibles
est ce que ça vous intéresse et si
toutefois ça nous intéressait quel
modèle pour vous faire craquer bien sûr
on n'a pas la fiche technique on ne
connaît pas tout on verra ça plus tard
mais dit mot en tout cas sur le papier
si ça pourrait voter autre question j'ai
des produits à tester
dites moi quels produits vous voulez
qu'on teste en premier voilà vous laisse
jeter un petit coup d'oeil vous le dites
ce qui vous intéresse le plus selon vous
voulez qu'on parle en premier
et comme ça on regardera ça directement
ensemble on se fera un test et ça sera
super cool c'est tout pour aujourd'hui
épisode un peu plus court merci à vous
d'être présent présente sur lâche-t-elle
toujours plus nombreux surtout nombreux
je donne rendez vous dès demain
soyez sages je vous embrasse et qu'on
laisse au niveau d'un
[Musique]